vous êtes prêts là oui on va faire une
interview fin de phrase
donc ça commence avec vous on fred je
vous dis le début de la phrase ou lite
la fin si je n'avais pas rencontré omar
et bien je serai décédé omar fred est
tellement drôle que que je ris tout le
temps ça c'est vrai emery en faire
l'essai est donné fred je ne sais pas si
je dois le dire ou non mais omar pierre
qui roule n'amasse pas mousse s'appelle
omar
ce que j'aime chez le pen c'est sais
rien il y avait senti bien bref la seule
chose qui me ferait aimer les hommes
c'est que vous marrer la peau -12 que
les autres hommes a effectivement un
noir et un blanc ensemble ça ça déménage
tous les deux on a un truc en commun
c'est qu'on déteste ce gros con de de
michel vosgien non directeur de la
socotec
oui c'est vrai
mais on n'est pas là pour donner son nom
en revanche on est fan de pascal obispo
chéri laisse nous te dire une fois pour
toutes que faisons l'amour
avant de nous dire adieu si je regarde
l'émission
franchement en maintenant on peut dire
qu'à canal c koi canal thierry cette
incroyable depuis la dernière fois est
ce que tu as beau si sûr devait se
souvenir d'une vanne à nous ça serait ce
serait un homme persuadé que sa femme le
trompe rentrer chez lui il dit à sa
femme chérie je sais tout avons su en
quelle année il est mort napoléon je
peux la refaire avec une autre vol ça
serait ces deux mecs qui sont dans un
mariage et s'approche du buffet et lundi
à l'autre jean pierre schoeller sert du
vin oui merci mais moi c'est yves cela
est passé on viendra regardera c'est la
télé publique dans les belles années du
canal dans les bureaux y avait beaucoup
de pierre lescure et d'alain de greef
vous appeler ça comme ça
chérie tu es vraiment un un homme et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible